elle est avec nous s'il vous plaît voilà
elle est belle comme un coeur elle
rendrait à la nouveau sexuelle et les
rôles sexuels à yann david et mercy
mathieu je sais que tu fais c'est
rarement la sq après tu va bouffer c'est
là donc c'est pour ça que je voulais
alors à y aller c'était toi qui va
bouffer un peu ah bon ça a été un petit
peu taquin brard et je vais venir sur
ton cas du tout et tu sais quand tu es
toujours la vérité donc ça quand on dit
tout à l'heure que c'est avec des gardes
du corps ont été à dépend pour qui sur
alstom en garde benalla sera un ami de
la famille ça veut dire qu un ami de la
famille est sky et vous pouvez tout nous
dire c'est à dire un ce que vous
connaissez avec sont bénins 2 est ce que
vous l'avez déjà rencontré physiquement
et 3 est ce que oui ou non il a été
votre garde du corps très bien alors m
déjà je ne vais pas répondre forcément
dans l'ordre que tu m'a proposé d'accord
on connaît insolente
je ne vais jamais dans l'ordre que tu me
proposes alors déjà on va revenir sur
les propos de mme née là ok je vais y
revenir et je vais en parler bien
évidemment parce qu'apparemment c'est ce
qui nous intéresse ici sur ce plateau à
val thorens choses aussi mais là on va
faire ben alors je pense qu'on s'en fout
donc non seulement nous intéresse aussi
bien la france que les téléspectateurs
ce n'est pas de savoir ce que j'ai pensé
des propos de bena là où mon ressenti je
pense que la france s'en fout totalement
qu'on soit bien d'accord faire
maintenant je pense que la france
d'ailleurs vous l'avais dit à la france
s'en fout totalement donc si on allait
sur ce qu'elle attend la france sont
très claires qui a été posée donc lors
de l'audition d'alexandre benalla c'est
à savoir est-ce qu'il a été
effectivement mon garde du corps ou pas
voilà cette question là qui peut être
utile et n'est plus cet encadrement la
réponse officiellement est d'ailleurs
j'avais déjà répondu auprès du magazine
libération ta grosse merde
ça n'a jamais été mon garde du corps et
n'a jamais été chargé alexandre vinolas
n'a jamais été chargé d'assurer la
sécurité
quoi que ce soit la mienne ou celle de
mon fils que ce soit de près ou de loin
très bien c'est qu'on soit bien d'accord
je sais pourquoi il est le père d'anne
on appelle déjà à temps excuses - yamcha
répondre ça a été très clair j'ai fait
un démenti le 9 août
dès le lendemain de la sortie de la news
preuve à l'appui de mon démenti
aujourd'hui en magasin s'avère assez bon
donc pour tous ceux qui m'accusent ici
des besoins particuliers en vous
entendant ça connaissez pas mais je vais
revenir ça ne me dérangerait sur moi
voilà c'est fait c'est dijon jusqu'au
toit ter sur deux ou trois questions et
après je promets je crois tout ce que tu
veux d'après deuxième question est ce
que oui ou non tu l'as déjà rencontré ce
que tu le konami
effectivement je les rencontre et oui je
le connais en quelques heures alors je
le connais je les rencontrer dans un
cadre privé familial amical parce que
tout simplement c'est l'ami intime de
mon ex mari
d'accord on soit bien d'accord
effectivement je l' ai rencontré à
plusieurs occasions car il a voyagé avec
moi comme ça a été dit très justement
par myriam en plus ce nom de domaine
privé comment il a voyagé dans des jets
privés où on s'en fout de ça c'est toi
que ça intéresse pas y apprendre j'en
suis pas vraiment à ça parce que je
crois c'est pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez un garde du corps je connais bien
sûr benhaddad tubulaire m'énerve
après je m'attaquerai sur autre chose
compte aux curieux à moncheaux soucis
comme l'a dit myriam palombes et c'est
ce que j'ai apprécié elle a fait un vrai
travail elle a fait preuve
d'intelligence pour la simple et bonne
raison que nous ne sommes pas amis et
qu'elle a rétabli la vérité en disant
qu'effectivement nous sommes retrouvés
tous les deux dans un avion dans un
cadre privé pour aller voir le papa de
mon fils d'accord j'ai qu'ils déposaient
mon enfant